I think so many technology companies are
trying to solve problems of people who
live in a few specific cities of this
particular country. When in reality,
building the future that we want or
that we'd be proud to hand to our kids,
involves humanity solving
problems at global scale.
This is Zipline Drone Delivery.
The startup founded in 2014 helped build
hype for a future filled with packages
falling conveniently from the sky. As
that future becomes more of a reality,
Zipline will have to compete with
the likes of Amazon's Prime Air.
Let me show you something.
Oh my God.
Remember when Jeff Bezos unveiled
an octocopter on 60 Minutes?
These are octocopters.
That was a decade ago. No octocopters yet,
but Amazon is making slow progress
and Alphabet's Wing is getting off the
ground as well.
Hello? Hey, thank you for
coming. Good to see you. No,
it's good to see you again. It's
been a while. Welcome to Zipline.
We serve eight countries. Today,
we serve about 3,500 hospitals
and health facilities globally.
It's become the largest
commercial-autonomous system on earth.
Zipline honed its technology
first in Rwanda, delivering blood,
vaccines and other medical supplies,
especially to rural areas that were
previously poorly served by land.
Does that give you chills that you
guys are out there saving lives?
It definitely never gets old,
especially when we get to
go spend time with doctors,
meet patients who are
benefiting from the system,
and it's been really cool
to see the system scale.
Can you show us how the magic
happens? Yeah, let's do it.
So this is Zipline's main manufacturing
area. Zipline has two products today.
Platform 1 is really focused on
enterprise delivery. Platform 2,
we're launching with
customers in a few months.
So that's the one that's going to be
delivering all the packages to my door?
Yep,
exactly. We're a pretty
full-stack company.
We're building LRUs or
line replaceable units.
So basically the
sub-assemblies of the aircraft.
It all happens here?
Yeah. You can think of this
as the ears of the aircraft.
So we're passing a huge
amount of air through here.
It's like a really quiet wind tunnel.
This is the paraland tube.
If we're encountering such insane
weather conditions or there is systematic
failure throughout the entire aircraft
and across multiple levels of redundancy,
then we can deploy the parachute and
we can bring the aircraft gently to the
ground. This is the reason that through
50 million commercial-autonomous miles,
Zipline has had zero human-safety
incidents. See these two holes?
You're going to line those up with
those two. I think I can do this. Nice.
You did it. Good job.
Oh. Not heavy at all.
Yeah, or you're really strong.
This is the advantage of
carbon fiber materials.
You can design something
that's really strong.
It's designed to go up
to about 3G's of load.
Where we are now, we call it Nest Zero.
This is actually the first test site.
What's the grand plan?
When we started building Zipline,
the more we thought about logistics,
the more we realized global logistics
really only does a good job of serving
people in the golden billion. So
the richest billion people on earth,
your access is probably OK.
But.
For the 7 billion people who
don't fall into that category,
your access either
sucks or is nonexistent.
And.
As a result of that,
5.5 million kids under the age of five
lose their lives every year due to lack
of access to basic medical products.
From a mission perspective,
what's exciting to us about building an
automated-logistics system is that we'll
be the first logistics system
that serves all people equally.
It will enable us to transition
logistics to zero emission.
It'll also enable universal access
to a lot of different products,
including lifesaving products.
So not to overly simplify it,
but is the goal to be like
a modern day UPS or FedEx?
Or is this something bigger?
I actually think the opportunity to
build a system that is 10 times faster,
half the cost, zero emission,
and broadly available to every
human on Earth is probably like 10
times or larger. Emily, this is Fabiola.
Hi. I started.
At Zipline four years
and a few months ago.
And it was Rwanda One. Yes.
It's basically members of the Rwanda
and Ghana flight operations teams now
having to train all of our US
team members on how to do this at
scale.
Three, two, one...
Alright.
That's amazing.
A ton of t-shirts. Oh,
t-shirts, guys. And water. So.
Prepared.
So is the goal to deliver
everything from blood to vaccines
to my Kleenex and sushi?
I mean, it turns out that our
customers want everything. In the US,
a good analogy with Walmart,
we had initially planned to launch with
them around their pharmacy business.
They're one of the largest
pharmacies in the US.
We launched delivering
healthcare products,
but very rapidly it was clear that
customers wanted to order everything.
And so today we deliver 24,000
of the 29,000 SKUs in the
store that we're attached to.
You do have competition, Amazon
Prime Air, Alphabet's Wing.
What makes you think you
can lead this market?
I think there are a lot of big companies
with kind of infinite resources talking
about this market, but talk
and walk are different things.
We are the largest commercial-autonomous
system on earth of any kind,
ground or air. So.
Compared to Amazon? You know...
A lot less. You'll have
to ask them that question.
Zipline's first delivery drones
were all about getting supplies.
To places with enough space to drop
packages from midair to the ground.
The company's Platform 2 is all about
precision and reaching more dense urban
areas.
One of the most important things about
making the overall system work is how do
we integrate with all the different
companies that want to take advantage of
this to essentially enable
teleportation from their businesses or
warehouses or stores directly to a home.
Zipline can basically show up and
install a magical portal in your wall.
That's kind of how we talk about it. It's.
A Harry Potter door.
Yeah. Or I think of like
a Rick and Morty door.
You can basically choose
what you want to load.
Do you have any preferences? I mean,
pizza and coffee. Pizza and coffee.
Everyone.
Has to have.
Pizza and coffee.
So.
I'll put the pizza in here
and you can do the coffee.
OK. I mean, is this going
to spill in there? OK.
Alright.
There you go. So you just
teleported something via Zipline.
That's it. Pretty.
Cool.
We need to be able to deliver silently
with dinner plate level accuracy.
This is the only thing that's coming
close to you, your family, your house.
It's really cute. It's not making
very much noise. It's totally safe.
What's going to happen to the
UPS guy? I mean, what about.
Jobs?
Any new technology,
there's always this worry that it's
going to put people out of jobs. So,
I think the reality is we are in a
world where unemployment is the lowest
basically it has been over
the last 30 years. Generally,
I think there are not enough humans to
do the work and labor that we want done
to live abundant, rich lives.